[Music]
finishing at the rim with lemon man play
right there see they not calm a thing
once again westward 32 points 13
rebounds 9 assists stolen sailor grant
coming in
[Applause]
with the bucket playing some defense now
broody eggs under the show in the lane
[Applause]
KC regarded by Simonis now
[Music]
19 now for yoke itch couldn't convert
chance there you get so frustrated
five Westbrook because the games turned
into a little bit of a get the
triple-double everybody standing up
folks
he's missed a triple-double by a couple
rebounds and one assist inside
[Applause]
pulled up that left they went out to the
hand he brought it back in right
rebounds three assists he's made seven
of ten now Westbrook trying to get by
this could be Russell Westbrook has
passed his wife
with his forty second
[Applause]
but nuggets tag on here I'll jump shots
to play Gallinari on the
[Applause]
and the long rebound bounces out
Westbrook coming in on Gallo you're all
step that's good - quick go get it into
Westbrook won't back down
within two seconds I'll get it into West
werewolf day yeah they do scores within
two seconds Murray West burrow
Kinney marrows happy
let's see if they review the timing here
well there's no doubt he got letters out
of timeouts Adams gives it back to raw
speed shot what a perfect ending
- historic day
Westbrook gives the Thunder the victory
at the buzzer
I'm speechless and I know I said please
say something right now folks but I'm
like you are back at Oklahoma City I am
speechless right now
what else can he do 2.9 what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more